guys don't like to think about women  haven't been with anybody before them at  all like no one at all they've preferred  and like  was closed before they got there and  then it opened and now it's in process  like they just can't they can't they  don't want to visualize it it's very  uncomfortable for them to do that so the  more Partners you've had the more you  start to seem like an open 24 hours  seven 24 hours a day seven days a week  seven eleven they're not into it it just  is also if they're looking at you  seriously they're looking saying this  could be the mother of my child gonna be  pregnant like you just it just it's a  clash like promiscuity and that family  it's just a clash in their head they  don't like it